hey what's happening everybody this is
Julie masse here I'll cover strafe
regret logic proposed to work together
we're bros
but actually doing it's not gonna crash
right
so cannot emphasize how wrong you're
being right now okay I like the angle of
your dangle I like the dangle of your
angle like the mirth of your girth wow
that was good thank you
I like the Venus of your penis three
gears to not look at the shapes but a
look at the hole
when the shouting in the middle of a
parking lot of lies thank you they look
black and scary up close but thanks for
watching all of the videos in this
compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye